huit heures de travail par semaine
durant un mois le rythme était cadencé
pour ces lycéens en agroéquipement et
horticulture pour créer cette yole
fleurissent une mosaïque culture en
trois dimensions composé de 28 variétés
différentes comme de l'herbe grasse du
doliprane des salades ou des plantes
ornementales par exemple imaginé dessiné
planté et même soudé
il a fallu tout créer pour moi là les
difficultés c'était plus de dire les
armatures avec la fira et la soudure
ça nous a demandé beaucoup de travail
pour 35 élèves de la première heure on a
travaillé tout ce qui est en mature de
laguiole idée vous ne récupérez le sable
l'a fait la butte
on a fait état de choses et on a surtout
fait des moues d'heure les modèles sont
les astuces de file avec la lazio le dos
au niveau des plantations tout ça a pris
beaucoup de temps
on a dû naturopathie plusieurs fois
certaines choses à cause du mot de sauce
tomate oui ça a promis de 10
la mosaïque monsieur opaque des
floralies les scolaires venus de toute
l'île visite les différentes expositions
des oeuvres de la martinique mais aussi
du canada de la russie du japon ou du
maroc des petits bouts sensiblement
nature sait trop ce que c'est bien que
cv intéressant pourquoi j'aime bien la
gueule comme ça c'est chaud c'est vrai
que c'est très joli la nation on peut
faire beaucoup de la chose avec
est ce que tu as vu des plantes ou des
fleurs que tu ne connaissais pas ah oui
j'ai vu toute la flotte différentes mais
je connais pas l'homme mais ils sont
très jolies durant cette semaine tous
les jours environ 900 scolaires sont
attendus au parc des floralies afin de
découvrir les richesses qu'offre la
biodiversité de la martinique et
d'ailleurs